Next, we turn our attention briefly to internet routing. That is,
what hops a packet will take to get from one endpoint
to the other. Let's say Georgia Tech student is curious about
what is going on at the MIT Media Lab. Of course
there is no direct link, so data is going to have
to take several intermediate hops. The essential data structure here is
a routing table that translates the IP address to the next
hop i.e. the address the package should be sent to next.
Every node on the internet should have a different routing table.
There is much that is interesting in the shortest path like
algorithms used to figure out what the next stop should be
and also in the implementation of the routing table. Should it
be a hash table? A tri? Etc. Here, however, I want
to address the question of the size of the table. In
a very naive approach, the routing table would require almost two
to the 32 entries, one for each IP address on the internet.
Fortunately this isn't necessary. Because IPs are
largely allocated based on region, similar IPs will
often take similar routes. For instance, consider
traffic between Georgia Tech and MIT. As mentioned
earlier, MIT owns the 18.0.0/8 address space.
Meaning that every IP that starts with 18,
needs to go to Boston and MIT campus. All the traffic from Georgia Tech to
MIT will likely follow the same first hop
or two, then only later split in Boston. Therefore,
Georgia Tech routers don't need 16 million entries for
MIT. One entry that matches anything starting with 18
suffices. All the traffic will be correctly routed up
towards Boston. This principle can be applied more broadly.
To keep the size of routing tables manageable. To
see the routing table on your machine, run nestat-nr.